well we begin this NewsHour with
breaking news a rescue operation is
currently underway to save dozens of
people off the British Coast their boats
sank in the English Channel and up to 50
migrants were thought to be on board
French Rescue Services are also said to
be taking part in the operation well
let's get more now from Andrew Simmons
he joins us from London Andrew I know
this is all happening as we speak but at
this stage what do we know
what we do know sources on the French
side are suggesting that something like
30 to 50 migrants were on board this
small boat which got into trouble uh off
the coast of Kent and it's thought it
capsized uh the waters are icy cold uh
Sub-Zero temperatures throughout the UK
in a really cold snap so the chances of
surviving for any length of time for
those people are absolutely really zero
so it is fair this is a major incident
uh there are a number of lifeboats
around the scene uh there is a an air
ambulance that's been dispatched the
Royal Navy is involved the police are
involved uh border Force are involved
everybody is doing their very best it
would seem to try to rescue uh people
but it does look Grim at this stage it's
thought that this this boat was heading
for either Dover or Dungeness which are
both Channel ports and we're also
learning that uh suela bravaman the uh
interior Minister the Home Secretary and
she's called the UK has said that she's
aware of this distressing incident and
she uh says that it's a cause of great
concern uh the issue of immigrants
coming across the channel is huge in the
UK only hours before this tragedy
happened uh the Prime Minister Rishi
sunak had been addressing uh MPS saying
that he had to find new laws to try and
stem the tide of migrants crossing the
channel
it appears that anything but a decrease
in this in this uh uh tide of people
coming over is happening it's increasing
and nothing really has been effective to
stop the tide of immigrants coming over
to attempt to get uh to get uh
Asylum uh uh in from a whole host of
countries uh in which these pen are
either escaping for economic reasons or
for political reasons uh they're leaving
their home countries Andrew Simmons
there for us with all the latest from
London will be staying across that story
for you here now to Zero thanks Andrew